cbs news contributor david becker joins
us now he's an election law expert and
founder of the center for election
innovation and research david good
morning to you
we spoke with ryan about the president's
legal challenges
and how they might work we have not seen
any evidence
could any of it work from a legal
perspective
well i don't see how there's really no
coherent strategy and nothing about this
is really normal
you know what we're seeing right now is
the trump campaign setting up impromptu
press conferences and making wild
baseless allegations and parking lots
and that's just not how litigation is
done if you've got a case you
accumulate facts and then you bring the
case and that's what was done in florida
2000 where two very competent teams of
of lawyers went down to accumulate facts
and litigate that over time
what we've got here is wild claims being
made and then a hotline is being set up
to try to get
information to support those claims
after the fact we have to remember that
a majority of votes
were cast actually two weeks ago
election day was six
days ago and we still have not heard any
facts that support any allegations of
any kind of systemic fraud or problems
in fact this is one of the smoothest
elections in history
important to point out now david on the
subject of that timeline you mentioned
december 8th is when electors from all
50 states are supposed to have certified
their results
and then one week after that they're
supposed to actually cast their ballot
in the electoral college for president
this is a very important milestone on
the process toward
the inauguration day could these
lawsuits disrupt that
very careful timeline well i think they
may be designed to do that but i think
the courts have been handling them very
well and very promptly what we're seeing
right now is basically the trump
campaign has lost every time they've
gone to court
they continue to do that there may be
more lawsuits brought today
i'm cautiously optimistic the courts
will continue to act diligently on this
and allow the states to proceed towards
their certification deadlines which
a lot of them are coming up this week
and next week and then we'll have
some some clarity on how the
president-elect will begin the
transition
so what is the trump administration
seeing david that legal experts are not
uh that's really hard to say i mean it
seems like they just don't want to
accept this result because what we're
hearing from republican election
officials in the states as you mentioned
republican commissioner of
city commissioner al schmidt in
philadelphia and many many others
they have confirmed this process has run
very smoothly there's
no concerns about the integrity of the
process
in fact if you look at the margins of
victory uh vice president vladimir put
biden president-elect biden is up by
five figures in states like wisconsin
pennsylvania georgia arizona nevada up
by six figures in michigan
these are not margins that will be
overturned by recounts all right
very important clear information there
david becker thank you very much